mein vortrag gliedert sich in zwei teile
und ein ganz kurzes fazit der erste
abschnitt hat die überschrift idealismus
in nach idealistischer zeit und ich
beginne mit einem längeren zitat unter
den verschiedenen denkern die die
periode des deutschen idealismus
hervorgebracht hat anerkannte man
allgemein auch jakob friedrich fries
nannte ihn mit achtung aber ging in
darstellungen der gedanken bewegung
seinerzeit doch zumeist sehr schnell an
ihm vorüber in der geschichte der
philosophie verschwand er vor den
angeblich größeren in der tat
erfolgreicheren denkern seinerzeit
hinter fichte und schelling und
besonders hinter hegel in der geschichte
der religionsphilosophie wiesmann wohl
auf eine gewisse verwandtschaft zwischen
fries und schleiermacher hin
hinsichtlich der lehre vom religiösen
gefühl hielt diesen aber für den
originalen und umfassenderen geist in
wahrheit ist fries in religionskunde
licher hinsicht nicht sowohl durch das
wenige was ihnen mit schleiermacher
verbindet als durch das was ihn von ihm
trennt besonders interessant und auch in
den gemeinsamen ist er ganz original und
bei genauem hinsehen umfassender
gründlicher und stichhaltiger zitat ende
mit dieser reminiszenz eröffnet rudolf
otto seine im jahre 1909 erschienene
kann tisch frische religionsphilosophie
zur einleitung in die glaubenslehre für
studenten der theologie dieses zitat ist
nun gleich in dreifacher hinsicht
geeignet um in meiner folgenden
ausführungen einzuleiten und sie im
rahmen des themas unserer tagung zu
verorten
zunächst ist erst einmal deutlich dass
sich rudolf autos idealismus rezeption
dadurch auszeichnet sich nicht an einem
der großen protagonisten fichte
schelling oder hegel zu orientieren
sondern vielmehr an einer zumindest
wirkungs geschichtlich zweitrangigen
statt wie dem herrn hutter und späteren
fichte schüler fries fragt man nach den
motiven für diese gestaltet der
idealismus rezeption so ist zuvörderst
auf den umstand hinzuweisen dass nach
dem tode hegels die spekulativen systeme
des deutschen idealismus rapide an
plausibilität verlieren und die debatten
spätestens in der zweiten hälfte des
neunzehnten jahrhunderts durch neue
wissenschafts paradigmen und sich daraus
ableitende weltanschauung bestimmt
werden
innerhalb der philosophie und theologie
wiederum führen diese paradigmenwechsel
zu tiefe orientierungskrise deren dass
es vermutlich nicht so viel gesagt nach
wirkung bis heute zu spüren sind
es verwundert daher nicht dass otto
seine wertschätzung für fries und das
damit verbundene idealismus bild mit
einer entsprechenden krisen diagnose
begründet es sei nach allem historismus
gerade für die religionswissenschaften
notwendig zu den fragestellungen des
deutschen idealismus zurückzukehren
das heißt zur zitat methodischen
aufsuchung der rationalen grundlagen der
religion im menschlichen geistes
zitat ende idealismus also als
philosophie des geistes verstanden in
einem ganz allgemeinen sinne da so otto
der maßstab für die wahrheit und
gültigkeit der historischen religion
nicht in der geschichte selbst gegeben
sein könne
der historismus also ebenso versage wie
der super naturalismus sei die suche
nach dem religiösen apriori dringendes
desiderat die verwandtschaft zu oder
parallelität mit den fragestellungen
ernst höss von denen wir ja eben gehört
haben ist offenkundig doch mit dem
hinweis auf das sogenannte historismus
problem lässt sich vielleicht erklären
dass otto der die
religionsgeschichtlichen arbeit
ausdrücklich bejaht und neben religion
psychologie und religion
sophie als eine der drei pfeiler einer
sich als christliche
religionswissenschaft verstehenden
theologie ansieht eine ungebrochene
rückkehr zur spekulativen
geschichtsphilosophie eines hegel
ähnlich wie träsch und andere
zeitgenossen für unmöglich hält
die methodische entfaltung der
historischen forschung im neunzehnten
jahrhundert führte ja bereits bei
ritschel zum bruch mit dem theologischen
hedonismus der neuen tübinger schule ein
wieder anknüpfen an die spekulative
geschichtsdeutung war zumindest unter
denen sich der ritschel schule
verpflichtet wissen den theologen was
eben ausdrücklich auch auf otto zutrifft
nicht mehr denkbar
doch mit diesem abkehr motiv ist
keineswegs schon die hinwendung zu fries
und dessen stilisierung zu einem zu
unrecht vergessenen idealisten
verständlich dies erhält erst wenn man
sich einen zweiten punkt vergegenwärtigt
die im titel von ottos
religionsphilosophie zum ausdruck
kommende verbindung von kant und friis
ist keineswegs willkürlich fries selbst
hat sich als kann die aber letztlich
sogar als einzig echten kann diana
verstanden
das wird vielleicht am prägnantesten an
seiner philosophie geschichte deutlich
fries lässt darin seiner kant
darstellung im vorletzten kapitel ein
abschluss kapitel folgen indem er sein
eigenes system der philosophie darstellt
und zwar als behebung der in der ganzen
lehre verbliebenen mängel und als
vollendung von dessen vernunft kritik
entsprechend programmatisch lautet auch
der titel seines philosophischen
hauptwerkes von 1807 neue oder
anthropologische kritik der vernunft
autos auszeichnung von fries ist somit
eine durchaus dessen eigenem
selbstverständnis entsprechende
programmatische orientierung an der
kanten vernunft kritik mit diesem durch
fries vermittelten wieder anknüpfen an
kant unter umgehung der großen systeme
eine fichte schelling und hegel reiht
sich otto nun aber auch das haben wir
bereits gehört
in eine verbreitete wenn auch in sich
vielfältige tendenz in der zweiten
hälfte des neunzehnten jahrhunderts ein
zu denken ist dabei nicht nur an den
theologischen kanzian ismus der ritze
schule sondern natürlich vor allem an
wilhelm dilthey projekt einer kritik der
historischen vernunft sowie die kultur
philosophie und wissenschaftstheorie des
südwestdeutschen neu kann tennis muss in
beiden fällen handelt es sich um eine
von ganz ähnlichen motiven getragenen
neuorientierung der philosophie in
gestalt einer kritischen und im lichte
der gegenwartsfragen weiterführenden
transformation der kantischen vernunft
kritik die dann wiederum die weiteren
entwicklungen im zwanzigsten jahrhundert
vorbereitet dass sich ein derartiger
kann jannis muss wie im falle von ottos
fries und auch selbst deutung dennoch
dem deutschen idealismus zugehörig weiß
ist insofern kein widerspruch als ja
auch die haupt repräsentanten des
deutschen idealismus selbst mit eben
jener programmatik einer vollendung der
kantischen vernunft kritik angetreten
waren und sich mehr oder weniger
vermittelt am stifter der
transzendentale philosophie abgearbeitet
haben
mit bezug auf das einleitende zitat
bleibt aber noch ein drittes autos auf
fallende verhältnis bestimmung von fries
und schleiermacher und zwar zugunsten
des ersteren sie irritiert nicht nur
weil otto spätestens mit seiner
berühmten jubiläumsedition der reden dem
anderen herrnhuter ein denkmal gesetzt
hatte sondern weil sich von da an die
inneren und tiefen bezüge zwischen
eigener religions- theorie und
schleiermacher bis ins hauptwerk ziehen
lassen
warum schreibt also so kann man
zugespitzt fragen otto keine kante
schleiermacher religionsphilosophie
zumal sich doch auch schleiermacher als
idealistisches systemdenken kritisch
gegenüber fichte schelling und hegel
positioniert und sie stärker als diese
an die kante gps-technologie gebunden
weiß wo liegen also die motive für autos
fries schwenk und
es sich durchaus um eine art
selbstkorrektur handelt macht otto an
besagter stelle in einer anmerkung
ausdrücklich wo er auf eine gegenläufige
verhältnis bestimmungen zwischen fries
und schleiermacher in einem seiner
früheren werke hinweist und diese nun in
der religionsphilosophie ausdrücklich
revidiert im besagten zitat bei dem
angesprochenen werk handelt es sich um
die fünf jahre vor der
religionsphilosophie also im jahre 1904
erschienene abhandlung mit dem titel
naturalistische und religiöse
weltansicht und meine these lautet dass
sich genau in der thematik dieses
erstaunlichen werkes das eigentliche
motiv für die hinwendung zu fries und
damit auch für die spätere gestalt
seiner religionsphilosophie findet warum
otto geht es in besagter studie um eine
rechtfertigung der religiösen
weltansicht gegenüber einem
weltanschaulichen naturalismus und
darwinismus
neben dem bereits genannten historismus
identifiziert er also im naturalismus
und evolution es muss eine zweite und
durchaus größere herausforderung für die
religionsphilosophie der gegenwart
im unterschied jedoch zur regelschule
und analogen strategien in den bereits
genannten philosophischen
hauptströmungen wo die natur als
genuiner gegenstand der
naturwissenschaft überlassen und die
aufgeklärte religion ganz in das gebiet
des sittlichen selbst verhältnisses des
geistes und dem bereich der kultur
verwiesen wird will sich der theologe
otto nicht mit dem rückzug aus der natur
gleichsam ihrem verstummen für das
religiöse erleben abfinden
und genau dieses anliegen bringt ihn
auch in distanz zur schleiermacher
rettung der schöpfung theologie in das
selbstbewusstsein der schlecht wenigen
abhängigkeit
religion kann sich nicht in das selbst
verhältnis des geistes und die welt der
kultur zurückziehen sondern hat nach
otto selbst ein eminentes interesse an
der natur wie er immer wieder mit dem
verweis auf die reichen symbol bestände
nicht nur des christentums sondern der
gesamten religionsgeschichte erinnert in
dieser grund intuition liegt somit nicht
nur das motiv dafür dass sich der junge
theologe detailversessen an der
hochgradig ausdifferenzierten
naturwissenschaftlichen fach forschung
der letzten jahrzehnte abarbeitet und
darin besteht das eigentlich
erstaunliche der besagten ersten schrift
sondern eben auch der grund dafür dass
gerade die frische kant deutung für ihn
systematisches potenzial entfalten wird
das ihnen fries nicht nur über den
theologischen vermittlungs weg also über
die wet begegnet sein wird sondern
gerade in seiner auseinandersetzung mit
dem naturalismus das interesse auf sich
zog ist zudem auch deswegen
wahrscheinlich da sich in der
sogenannten friesischen schule nicht
wenige zeitgenössische naturforscher
befanden unfalls sind im naturalismus
buch bereits deutliche ansätze so
späteren religionsphilosophie erkennbar
zur frage etwa ob sich im natur erkennen
selbst transzendenz momente aus machen
ließen heißt es förmlich zitat dieser
frage gründlich nachdenken hieß eine
eigene erkenntnis und science lehre
aufstellen das kann ich hier nicht kann
hier nicht die aufgabe sein zitat ende
die fünf jahre später vorgelegte kannte
frische religionsphilosophie kann
zumindest eingeschränkt als erfüllung
dieses dwd rats angesehen werden die
grundlinien dieser in diesem sinne dann
erkenntnis und science lehre möchte ich
daher im folgenden skizzieren dabei
werde ich mich aber auf die umformung
des kantischen idealismus beschränken
und die schwierige detailfragen die ich
ehrlich gesagt selber noch nicht in
gänze überblicke was dabei auf das konto
von fries de wet oder otto selbst zu
buchen ist gar nicht erst aufwerfen
otto selbst jedenfalls beansprucht hier
von der didaktischen aufbereitung zur
problematik für studierende theologie
abgesehen keinerlei originalität
damit komme ich zu meinem zweiten teil
die umformung der kanten vernunft kritik
führt man sich den gesamt aufriss vor
augen so überrascht zunächst eine recht
konventionelle also hinterhand gleichsam
auf die klassische schule philosophie
zurückverweisen eine gliederung des
stoffes denn otto unterteilt seine
darstellung gleichsam in einen
theoretischen und einen praktischen teil
und orientiert sich damit äußerlich an
der folge und den titeln von fries
publikationen die der theoretischen
philosophie in der neuen kritik ein
handbuch der praktischen philosophie
folgen ließen
diese wie es seit der antike üblich war
er es der psychologie entlehnte
zweigliedrige strukturierung des
philosophischen systems verwundert
jedoch nicht nur insofern als sich ab
der zweiten hälfte des 18ten
jahrhunderts die unterteilung in
theoretisches und praktisches vermögen
um ein drittes erweitert hat kann selbst
hat dazu maßgeblich beigetragen was
nicht zuletzt an der drei zahl seiner
kritiker sich widerspiegelt
schleiermacher hat bekanntlich darauf
aufbauen danach gerade
religionsphilosoph isches kapital aus
dieser innovation geschlagen
zugleich aber das dritte vermögen wir
haben es in der diskussion auch schon an
gestreift systematisch mit der einheits
problematik und damit mit der
fragestellung verbunden mit der der
deutsche idealismus gerade die
vermögens- psychologischen reste bei
kant zu überwinden suchte in anbetracht
all dieser konstellation muss
festgehalten werden dass ottos
friesische stoff disposition nur
äußerlich ist und bei beiden die
genannten sachfragen wie wir noch sehen
werden durchaus und auch gegenläufig zu
dieser unzulänglichen gliederung eine
zentrale rolle spielen
um also mit dem theoretischen teil zu
beginn so kreis dieser grob gesprochen
um zwei große themen
zunächst wird die theorie des
kategorialen natur erkennens kritisch
rekonstruiert sodann wird kann es
theorie der vernunft ideen einer
tiefgreifenden transformation unterzogen
beide seiten sind jedoch innerlich
miteinander verzahnt dass die kategorien
und ideen lehre zusammen bindende
theorie ist die doppelte verneinung
bevor ich jedoch den sinn dieser
negation sleep logischen figur erläutern
kann ist zunächst kurz auf die kritische
aneignung der karnischen kategorien
kategorien lehre einzugehen
neben der pflicht schuldigen darstellung
der grundlegenden einsichten und
verdienste cantz allen voran der urteils
theoretischen ableitung der kategorien
tafel findet sich jedoch bereits in
diesem zusammenhang eine fundamentale
kritik
sie wird mit der formel zusammengefasst
kant habe fälschlicherweise aus der
priorität der kategorien auf ihre ideale
tät geschlossen wobei mit ideal i tät
die kahn'sche these gemeint ist dass es
sich bei den kategorien um subjektive
form prinzipien handle die keinen
anspruch auf gültigkeit zur bestimmung
des an sich seins der dinge erheben
könnten
vielmehr würden die kategorien erst
vermöge ihrer anwendung auf die
sinnliche mannigfaltigkeit der
anschauung anspruch auf objektive
gültigkeit erhalten so kann dieser in
kants diktion formulierte empirische
realismus wird nun aber von otto fries
folgend in einen höheren realismus
umgedeutet demzufolge bereits die reinen
kategorien und entsprechend auch
diakonischen anschauungs formen anspruch
auf objektive geltung und science
erkenntnis haben sollen
die einlösung dieser these umfasst
mehrere argumentation schritte zunächst
wird eine zentrale voraussetzung die
konstruiert
von kant werde nämlich zitat die
kausalität des gegenstandes auf uns zum
kriterium der objektiven gültigkeit der
kategorien erklärt
das setze aber offensichtlich bereits
die geltung der kausalität kategorie
voraus wie bereits bei fichte und man
kann sagen bis gerhold rausch setzt also
die otto fritzsche hand kritik bei der
rezeptiven problematik bzw
weiter gefasst bei dem problem des ding
an sich an die otto frische auflösung
jedenfalls folgert aus der
angesprochenen zirkular i tät das
bereits den reinen kategorien objektive
gültigkeit zugewiesen werden müsse und
in ihnen somit eine reine vernunft
erkenntnis vorliegt damit wird freilich
der kante begriff von objektiver
erkenntnis stillschweigend preisgegeben
diese gleichsam nicht auf den
empirischen verstandes gebrauch
beschränkte art von erkenntnis die zitat
grunderkenntnis von der notwendigkeit
und einheit alles sein denn überhaupt
zitat ende
die fries dann unter der kategorie des
glaubens als eine höhere art von
erkenntnis vom empirischen wissen
unterscheidet kann damit zum
eigentlichen der adoptions grund der
kategorien aufgewertet werden kategorien
werden also als diskursive
ausdifferenzierung jenes in science von
einheit und seien durch die vernunft
verstanden
kurz auch das wahrheit' gefühl
kategorien muss also nicht erst geltung
zu wachsen schon gar nicht durch die
sinnliche wahrnehmung sondern sie haben
ihre gegenstands bestimmende funktion
die kanzlerin dental philosophie für die
natur erkenntnis nachgewiesen habe
gerade weil sie variation einer
fundamentalen geltung intuition der
vernunft sind
mit dieser app is theologischen
aufwertung der kategorien ist zugleich
der übergang zu ideen lehre gewarnt
dabei werden zwei theorie elemente ganz
aus ihrem jeweiligen system kontext
herausgelöst und miteinander verbunden
die rede ist zum einen vom sogenannten
schematismus und grundsatz kapitel zum
anderen von cannes santino mien lehre
verkürzt lässt sich die argumentation so
zusammenfassen
zunächst wird die zuvor kritisierte
ideal i tät der kategorien
das heißt also ihr bloß auf erscheinungs
gegen gestellen gegenstände
eingeschränkte geltung auf deren
zeitliche auf ihre zeitliche
thematisierung und vorstellung gemäß der
anschauungs form zurückgeführt während
bei kant die schema visierung der
kategorien einen elementaren beweis
schritt innerhalb der reduktion der
kategorien erfüllt wird in dieser lesart
allein die bei kann freilich auch
enthaltene restriktion these betont die
anwendung der kategorien auf die
bedingungen unserer sinnlichkeit hat
deren ideal i tät im sinne einer
eingeschränkten geltung zur folge diese
restriktion betrifft aber eben nicht die
geltung intuition der kategorien selbst
sondern gleichsam nur deren apples
technologische anwendung in einem
zweiten schritt wird diese these nun
anhand der anti nomi lehre cantz
bekräftigt mit seiner rekonstruktion der
kosmologischen antinori inside hand eine
zitat dramatische vorführung zitat ende
der inneren widersprüche eines
naturalistischen weltbildes gelungen in
seinem naturalismus buch dass diese
these bis in die kleinsten verästelungen
der zeitgenössischen fach forschung an
der zeitgenössischen fach forschung
durchführt kann in diesem kontext sogar
den kosmologischen gottesbeweis ex
kontingents amundi eine positive
funktion zugewiesen werden nicht etwa
als begründung eines objektiven wissens
vom dasein gottes wohl aber als auf weiß
der begrenztheit des naturalistischen
weltbildes
angesichts der auch vom
naturwissenschaftlichen
erkenntnisinteresse herr legitimen frage
warum ist denn überhaupt etwas und nicht
viel mehr nicht
der bereich des empirischen wissens
zeigt sich also letztlich als in sich
apolitisch und in jedem fall um
abschließbar was kant aus der zeitlichen
thematisierung der kategorien also
aufgeklärt habe an denen durch die
anschauungs formen evozierten antinori
des cosmo logischen denkens werde
augenscheinlich dass das durch den
naturalismus vermittelte weltbild zitat
das wesen der welt an sich selber zitat
ende gleichsam nur durch einen noch mal
ein zitat nebel zu erkennen gebe mit
dieser zugleich und mit und gegen kant
vollzogenen argumentation ist nun aber
die basis für die besagte doppelte
verneinung als zugangs operation zu den
ideen gelegt mit der ersten verneinung
ist die restriktion der kategorien auf
die bedingungen der sinnlichen
anschauung gemeint mit der zweiten
negation soll diese wiederum aufgehoben
werden um so die konstitutive funktion
der kategorien für eine zitat rein
vernünftige weltanschauung zu
ermöglichen
damit ist die systematische
schnittstelle zur entfaltung der
spekulativen ideen erreicht
mit der direkten ableitung der ideen aus
den kategorien ist freilich der wohl
tiefste widerspruch zur kanten vorlage
gegeben die ja bekanntlich die vernunft
ideen durch eine schluss logische
rekonstruktion entwickelt diese für kann
schlechterdings fundamentale
voraussetzung entfällt und damit
verschiebt sich zugleich auch die
architektonisch des spekulativen
gebäudes bevor ich die spekulativen
ideen kurz anführe ist jedoch zu merken
anzumerken dass der zweite negation
schritt also die rücknahme der ersten
negation in gestalt der restriktion eine
gewisse unschärfe besitzt denn der
anschein trügt als würde die bloße
aufhebung des sinnlichen schematismus
bereits eine spekulative
konstituieren diese müsste dann
sozusagen identisch sein mit der reinen
kategorie was aber offensichtlich nicht
gemeint ist vielmehr müsse über diese
negation hinaus diese zweite ein zitat
idealer schematismus zitat ende auf die
kategorie ahlen und unrecht regierten
form prinzipien angewandt werden
worunter dann gleichsam so etwas wie
eine spekulative verfahrensregeln zur
vollständigen synthesis rainer
mannigfaltigkeit vorgestellt wird
auf diese weise gelangt otto zu vier
spekulativen ideen die allerdings nicht
einheitlich den vier kategorien gruppen
zugeordnet werden vielmehr wird der
erste begriff oder die erste idee
nämlich die idee des absoluten science
aus den kategorien der quantität
qualität und modalität abgeleitet
während die drei metaphysischen
relations' kategorien zu der klassischen
trias von seele freiheit und gottheit
hypos kassiert werden
angesichts dieser ableitung der
spekulativen ideen und ihrer app ist
ökologischen aufwertungen zu
erkenntnissen scheint eine abgrenzung
von dem was kant als polizei lose
vernunft oder dogmatismus unbedingt
vermeiden wollte kaum möglich zu sein
doch so sehr sich im bereich der
erkenntnistheorie trotz des ausgangs von
kannte akzent von ihm weg hin zu einer
spekulativen ontologie von geltung cent
täten verschiebt so sehr überrascht dann
im zweiten als praktisch überschriebenen
system teil wiederum der enge anschluss
an cantz bewusstseins theorie weniger
allerdings nach maßgabe der zweiten
kritik denn der kritik der urteilskraft
die geister logische begründung der
religion steht genau in diesem
spannungsverhältnis also zwischen einer
spekulativen ontologie von geltung
center täten und einer nach maßgabe der
kritik der urteilskraft recken
rekonstruierten theorie
des religiösen bewusstseins otto bringt
es auf die prägnante formel zitat die in
unmittelbarer erkenntnis der vernunft
gründende überzeugung die sich in
solchen ideen ausspricht ist selber
durchaus nicht religion sondern kalte
und formale metaphysik während religion
im gegensatz zur metaphysik in gemüt und
willen ihr leben hat zitat ende
dieses leben so lautet dann jedoch die
gegenläufige these sei aber nicht
möglich ohne metaphysische vorstellung
noch einmal zitat metaphysik freie
religion kann es gar nicht geben punkt
und zitat ende
der übergang in die religions- theorie
schließt also unmittelbar an die ideen
lehre an und setzt diese voraus taucht
sie dabei aber nachträglich in ein
kritisches licht denn so otto mit fries
und eben auch mit kant diese
spekulativen ideen würden inhaltsleer
bleiben wenn sie nicht aus der
praktischen vernunft einen belebenden
inhalt erhielten das in den passagen zur
kategorien lehre fast gänzlich
unterdrückte zwei quellen prinzip
demgemäß bloße begriffe sinn und
bedeutung fehlt wird somit auf der ebene
der ideen lehre rehabilitiert die durch
doppelte negation gewonnene höhere
erkenntnis der ideen sei gar keine
positive erkenntnis sondern habe in
ihrer metaphysischen expedition er den
status eines begreifens des
unbegreiflichen als unbegreifliches um
es mit einer formulierung fichtes
zusammenzufassen
trotz der sich nicht nur hier zeigen
nähen grenzt sich jedoch gerade in
diesem kontext otto aber gegenüber den
großen idealisten besonders deutlich ab
es gebe keinen absoluten standpunkt oder
eine intellektuelle anschauung der
vernunft ideen ihr inhalt entziehen sich
dem positiven begreifen und können nur
via negation ist oder eminenz je mit
bezug auf unsere natürlichen
vorstellungen denkbar sei
otto erinnert hier ebenso an die
tradition der negativen theologie wie an
den deus ex aus luthers die servo der
geheim das geheimnisvolle ganz andere
dass die dialektischen theologen dann
kurzzeitig um begeisterung für autos
hauptwerk versetzte wird bereits hier in
der transzendentale philosophie
entfaltet was aber ist nun genauer unter
der positiven belebung jener ideen in
gemüt und willen zu denken hier ist
zunächst festzuhalten dass otto fries
folgend unter die praktische vernunft
auch das ästhetische und religiöse
bewusstsein subsummiert somit ist also
zwischen dem praktischen vermögen in
einem weiten und einem engen sinne zu
unterscheiden
für das verständnis des praktischen
vermögens im übergreifenden sinne wird
nun aber wie bereits angedeutet kants
kritik der urteilskraft maßgeblich für
das sittliche ästhetische und religiöse
bewusstsein ist die urteil struktur
grundlegend
dabei wird das urteilsvermögen in dieser
dimension der höheren vernunft jedoch in
kritischer umformung von kant als
leistung des gefühls aufgefasst gefühl
so kann otto kurz und prägnant zusammen
fassen ist zitat eigentümliches urteilen
über ein sinnlich gegebenes zitat ende
die ganze struktur analyse des
ästhetischen urteils die seinerseits dem
gefühl ja eine konstitutive rolle
zumisst wird dabei in zweifacher
hinsicht angereichert gleichsam kann's
ästhetische und ethische theorie
zusammenführen werden die gefühlsmäßigen
urteile über die sinnliche unlust
lustige toni bis hin zu reinen achtung
ausgedehnt die eben nicht mehr an
sinnlichen kriterien orientiert ist der
umfassende begriff für diese
gefühlsmäßige urteile ist der wert
begriff gefühle sind werturteile das
zieht aber die frage nach der wert
erkenntnis an sich nach sich
entschuldigt
gefühlen wird somit zweitens eine nicht
auf eine subjektiv sinnliche
zuständigkeit wie bei schleiermacher
beschränkte kognitive funktion
zugewiesen
neben dem oben bereits angeführten motiv
wird vor allem diese psychologische
konkretion des gefühls begriffs ottos
sympathien für fries begründet haben und
im lichte der heutigen emotionsforschung
kann man sagen zu recht
im falle des religiösen gefühls nun
besteht diese erkenntnis in der ahnung
entschuldigung einer metaphysischen idee
einmal muss ich den begriff erwähnen die
als dritte erkenntnis typ neben wissen
und glauben unterschieden wird mit der
psychologischen implementierung der
ideation als funktion des gefühls und
somit wird somit die spekulative ideen
lehre in die theorie des religiösen
bewusstseins überführt durch die
verschränkung mit der urteils theorie
wird aber die realisation dieser
erkenntnis dieser ahnenden erkenntnis
der ideen zugleich in eine komplexe
deutung struktur integriert die ideen
erschließen sich dem religiösen
bewusstsein nur in gestalt einer
gefühlsmäßigen deutung oder eben
bewertungen der empirischen wirklichkeit
darin ist der grund sinn der forderung
einer praktischen realisation der ideen
zu erblicken
gefühlsmäßig bedeutet dabei dass die uhr
teils mäßige suchfunktionen unter eine
metaphysische idee unter einen wert von
prädikat eve ist das gefühl vertritt
gleichsam den ewigkeit sind der
metaphysischen idee und bleibt diskursiv
nicht vollständig auf lösbar
zugleich besteht in dieser
gefühlsmäßigen repräsentation von ideen
aber auch eine ausdrucks relation die
als geist philosophische quelle der
religionsgeschichte mitsamt ihrer
theologischen rationalisierung
verstanden werden muss
die letzte konnte dieser kantischen
religionsphilosophie besteht nun darin
dass diese emotions theoretische
rekonstruktion des religiösen
bewusstseins noch einmal und darin wird
erneut die orientierung an cantz dritter
kritik deutlich mit der differenzierung
von ästhetischen und praktischen
bewusstsein verschränkt wird die
religiöse wertungs funktion kann sich
sowohl praktisch wie ästhetisch
konkretisieren und stellt jeweils eine
spezifische die tiefendimension bei der
realisation gestaltung des geistes da
die konkretion dieser grundstruktur die
konkretion dieser grundstruktur folgt
dann dem von fries und de wet
vorgezeichneten schema innerhalb der
dimension der praktischen wert setzung
oder wie er auch sagen kann werth
ansetzung weil es wird immer an etwas
weltlichen sinnlichen empirischen an
urteilen angesetzt also bei einer
bestimmten handlungsmaxime et cetera pp
bei der das sei mit bezug auf die
geschichte der ethik kurz erwähnt der
wert der menschenwürde das höchste
prinzip darstellt werden die
metaphysischen ideen dann einer
praktischen bestimmung zugeführt
das heißt sie werden zu handlungs
bestimmenden zweck vorstellungen
fortgebildet deren motivation aale kraft
sich durch die evaluationen gefühle wie
etwa die beseitigende begeisterung oder
die demütige ergebenheit oder der
zuversichtlichen andacht einstellen
während für diese praktische gestalt des
religiösen bewusstseins die
gegenständlichen symbole eines
christlichen es muss eine
vermittlungsfunktion haben lassen sich
die religiösen gefühle aber eben auch
unter ästhetischen ideen
wie dem schönen und vor allem dem
erhabenen auch in einer nicht
gegenständlichen weise evozieren hier
klingt die ideale welt gleichsam nur als
tiefendimension im anschaulich
wahrgenommenen an ohne seinerseits oder
ihrerseits noch mal gegenständlich
vorgestellt zu werden
während sich die bestimmung logische
ausdifferenzierung die sich durch die
von der spekulativen metaphysik auch in
den praktischen teil durch zieht dann
auf der ebene der ausdrucksformen
identifiziert wird was dann
fries und de weert folgend mit goethes
schema poetologischen schema des
epischen dramatischen und lyrischen
gezeigt wird damit komme ich zum schluss
mit seiner einen kurzen ausblick
fazit mit seiner kantischen
religionsphilosophie hat otto die seiner
meinung nach für die empirische
religionsforschung erforderliche geist
philosophische grundlegung durchgeführt
er wird diesen boden das sei gegen
anderslautende interpretation der werke
geschichte gesagt nicht mehr verlassen
und die grundprämisse dieser
religionsphilosophie bis in das spätwerk
beibehalten
freilich gewinnt die religions-
geschichtliche und religionspädagogische
arbeit eine eigendynamik die den ein
oder anderen frischen schematismus
zugunsten einer stärkeren orientierung
an der historischen vielfalt oder anders
formuliert die das rationale hinter dem
irrationalen in der idee des göttlichen
zurücktreten lässt
doch die tendenz ist in der
religionsphilosophie methodisch bereits
angelegt die dort im anschluss an frisch
gewählte methodische selbstbeschreibung
kann nach gerade für ottos weiteres
forschungsprogramm gelten mit dem
kantischen idealismus so resümiert otto
ist die zitat bahn frei für eine
unvoreingenommene untersuchung ob und
welche prinzipien sich rein durch innere
selbst beobachten
in innere erfahrung auf hinten lassen
zitat ende
dass es sich dabei um prinzipien handelt
die ihren geltung sgr und in selbst
verhältnis des geistes haben und in
diesem sinne ab rio risch sind
gleichwohl aber nur im erlebnis haften
nach vollzug und einem darin fundierten
verstehen der religionsgeschichte
entfaltet werden können gilt nicht
zuletzt für das hauptwerk für das
heilige und seine werke geschichtliche
entwicklung
diese lediglich mit blick auf die
religionsphilosoph ische anwendung und
somit natürlich verglichen jetzt mit den
großen idealistischen system nicht von
ferne systematisch entfaltete geist
philosophie versucht also grund
einsichten des spekulativen idealismus
in nach idealistischer zeit zur
formulierung und das scheint mir
besonders eigentümlich zu sein eben mit
den positiven sowohl den natur als auch
kulturwissenschaften abzugleichen oder
in vermittelbar zu machen
daher ist es wenig verwunderlich dass
ich gerade für ein derartiges synthese
programm eben diese anthropologische
psychologische idealismus friesischer
prägung nachher legte vor allem die in
diesem rahmen entfaltete theorie des
religiösen bewusstseins scheint mir für
die heutige religionsforschung ein
ausreichend komplexes und zugleich
hinreichend allgemeines konzept
bereitzustellen und ist in vielerlei
hinsicht an gegenwarts debatten
anschlussfähig was die lediglich
skizzierten metaphysischen
voraussetzungen betrifft so setzt sich
otto mit diesem versuch einer synthese
von idealismus und empirische einzel
forschung freilich vielen begrünung
problemen aus oder um es anders zu
formulieren zwischen alle stühle
doch wie bereits einleiten gesagt
befindet er sich damit in prominenter
gesellschaft und es ist mit blick auf
die neue philosophie geschichte ja auch
nicht absehbar ob sich der
systemgedanken überhaupt wird re
formulieren lassen vom theorie design
her kann man die umformung diese um form
und gestalt des idealismus jedenfalls am
ehesten
wie ich meine zwischen den teils
psychologische hermeneutik der
geisteswissenschaften und max schillers
phänomenologische wert philosophie
verorten
entsprechend lassen sich und wurden die
gegenüber diesen entwürfen formulierten
anfragen etwa an einen wert realismus
oder eben vor allem den methodischen
status des psychologischen auch auf otto
übertragen
eine gewisse gelassenheit in der
diskussion dieser fragen kann man
zumindest aus der erinnerung daran
gewinnen dass es sich auch dabei nur um
transformations- gestalten von
sachproblemen handelt die bereits der
klassische deutsche idealismus kannte
man denke nur an die stichworte höhere
realismus oder tatsachen oder geschichte
ist bewusstseins ich danke für ihre
aufmerksamkeit